alors pardon des masques que certains
voudraient les rendre obligatoires dans
l'espace public ça n'est pas prévu pour
le moment
en revanche il serait obligatoire dans
les transports publics ça vous paraît
une nécessité cette fois bon je pense
que les masses sur une bonne chose pour
que les gens n'aient pas trop peur de
déconfinement parce qu'on leur a
tellement sur la tête que c'était
dramatique
effectivement si du jour au lendemain
alors dit rien dans les transports en
commun suivez moi ça m'a toujours par le
raisonnable du tt raisonnable que au
mois de mars effectivement dans les rer
tassé on est les masques
c'était là où il fallait vraiment en
avoir bon à l'heure actuelle on est
enfin d'épidémie mais enfin être
raisonnable dans les transports en
commun ça me paraît bien tout le temps
dans la rupture ment pas parce que les
masques ne sont pas sans danger et j'en
profite pour le dire je vois je vois un
certain nombre de gens qui sont tout
seuls dans leur voiture avec leur masque
le porter un masque n'est pas sans
inconvénients en particulier chez les
personnes âgées qui ont éventuellement
en fonction respiratoire un peu moins
bonne au bout d'un moment ça fait ça
baisse la pression de si cher
donc il faut les mettre en a besoin je
suis d'accord mais pas tout le temps
tout le temps il faut pas que ça
devienne du fétichisme
à
[Musique]